Iraq's Parliament has just elected a new
president
joins us from Baghdad now so what more
can you tell us
well finally a new president of the
Republic has been elected after one year
of a political instability as you know
uh Latif Rasheed a former minister of
water resources in the government and
academic with PhD in engineering and a
senior advisor for the president of Iraq
has been elected has won actually
162 votes against 99 votes for incumbent
president Barham both of them are could
both of them belong to the Patriotic
Union of Kurdistan one of the major
political parties in the Kurdish region
based in suleimania Province now the
question now is whether or not
the new the newly elected president
would be able to assign a new prime
minister to form a the government given
the fact that this is so controversial
and has been behind all the political
upheaval sweeping over the country for
the past year including the latest
violence inside the green zone by those
supporters of the Shiite leader and
influential political figure
Now by political Norm
in fact by virtue of the Constitution
the newly elected president has 15 days
to assign uh the nominated prime
minister to form a government the
question now is whether or not the
coordination framework the political or
parliamentary block that is Affiliated
to Iran which has the largest Block in
the parliament now following the
withdrawal of the lawmakers Affiliated
in June now the Iranian parliamentary
Bloc has the majority of the largest
Block in the parliament they now by
virtue of the Constitution have the
right to nominate a new prime minister
if they present a new prime minister to
the newly elected president of the
Republic to form a government they have
a controversial figure too Muhammad
Sudani is the nominee of the pro-iranian
coordination framework for prime
minister the question now is whether or
not this a newly illuminated prime
minister will be accepted or whether or
not the president of the Republic will
be able to assign him to form a
government in the middle of this
political and revelry and deep division
between the Parliamentary blocks
okay Market Abdullah live with that news
from Iraq thank you